T
EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME TEAM AND
YOU'RE ON THE WRONG TEAM.
IT IS THAT?
GLENN GREENWALD HAS BEEN
WATCHING CAREFULLY AND THE
JOURNALIST THAT WRITES ON SUB
STACK.
JOINING US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
WOULD YOU MAKE OF THIS?
THE REALIGNMENT OR THE PREVIOUS
ALIGNMENT?
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT?
>> IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING AND I
KNOW YOU REMEMBER AND STARTED
WRITING ABOUT POLITICS IN 2005
SO I KNEW HOW LIBERALS USED TO
BE OVERFLOWING WITH SO MUCH
HATRED AND CONTEMPT FOR
GEORGE BUSH.
THEY FREQUENTLY COMPARED HIM TO
ADOLF HITLER, CLAIMED HIS FAMILY
WAS CRUCIAL TO THE PARTY, WERE
CRIMINALS SAID HE WAS FILLED
WITH RACISM THAT HE PURPOSELY
ALLOWED NEW ORLEANS TO DROWN
BECAUSE SO MANY BLACK PEOPLE
LIVED THERE.
GEORGE BUSH STOLE AT LEAST ONE
ELECTION AND MAYBE EVEN TWO IN
20,002,004.
THEY CONCOCTED THE PERSON AND
YOU CAN GET MUCH WORSE THAN
THAT.
YOU ARE SUDDENLY IN TRUMP YEARS,
I DIDN'T AGREE WITH GEORGE BUSH
ALL THE TIME BUT I NEVER
QUESTIONED HIS CHARACTER AND HIS
VALUE, HIS PATRIOTISM.
THIS WEEKEND IT TURNED INTO THIS
LOVEFEST.
THEY DRIPPED WITH ABUSIVE PRAISE
FOR HIM BECAUSE WHAT HE SAID
THERE IS ESSENTIALLY THE 9/11
ATTACKS HE WAS THERE TO
COMMEMORATE ARE THE SAME AS THE
THREE HOUR RIOT ON JANUARY 6TH.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE PEOPLE WHO
DID 9/11, AL QAEDA ARE SIMILAR
OR IDENTICAL TO THE SAME BALL
SPIRIT AS HE PUT IT.
AND TRUMP SUPPORTERS ESSENTIALLY
AND THEY OUGHT TO BE TREATED THE
SAME.
WAR ON TERROR AGAINST AL QAEDA
AND NOW HE DOMESTIC WAR ON
TERROR AGAINST YOUR FELLOW
CITIZENS IS MUSIC TO THE EARS OF
AMERICAN LIBERALS BECAUSE THEY
WANT NOTHING MORE THAN A NEW
DOMESTIC WAR ON TERRORISM AND
TREATING THEIR POLITICAL
ADVERSARIES LIKE THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION TREATED AL QAEDA.
>> Tucker: AT SUCH A LUNATIC
AND EXTREME THING TO SAY.
THE COMPARE PEOPLES POLICIES,
WHY IS IT NOT INSTANTLY
DISQUALIFYING?
SPEAK OF REASON IS
BECAUSE OF POLITICAL PRIORITY.
IF I SPEND MORE TIME REPORTING
ON THIS THAN ANY OTHER TOPIC AND
THE POLITICAL PRIORITY OF THE
CLASS TO LAUNCH A NEW DOMESTIC
WAR ON TERROR.
YOU CAN GO BACK TO YOU BEFORE
JANUARY 6TH, NOVEMBER 2012 TO
COME AND SEE ARTICLES ON
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" WHERE
JOE BIDEN WAS SAYING MY TOP
PRIORITY AS PRESIDENT ONCE I GET
INAUGURATED WILL BE TO COMBAT
DOMESTIC EXTREMISM.
AN ARRAY SIXTH HAPPENED, THAT
BECAME THE PRETEXT FOR DOING IT
LIKE A LOT OF WHAT HAPPENED,
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE USING
JANUARY 6TH.
IT'S DEMENTED TO COMPARE 9/11 TO
JANUARY 6TH BUT IT'S SO CENTRAL
TO THE AGENDA OF THE SECURITY
STATE, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, TO
INITIATE A SURVEILLANCE REGIME
AND THE TENSION REGIME AGAINST
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT WHO ARE
AGAINST THE ESTABLISHMENT.
THEY ARE DOING AT AND THEY PUT
PEOPLE ON THE NO-FLY LIST, THE
DEFINING FEATURE, NEW
LEGISLATION THAT GIVES THE FBI
AND THE CIA NEW POWER, SPENDING
MORE MONEY ON LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE WAR ON TERROR IS CRUCIAL.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY RIGHT AND
IT'S NOT JUST GOING TO KEEP
GOING ON THE RIGHTS, IT'S ANY
DI